this might be the best college
basketball team we have ever seen and
I'm not being dramatic the LSU Women's
Basketball team is stacked but it's not
like one of those perfect on paper
stories that never seemed to work out
they absolutely dominated preseason and
now they're sitting nice and pretty as
the number one team in the nation so
who's on this team anyway and what makes
them so good we have Angel Reese and F
Johnson returning for the Tigers they
LED LSU to last season's national title
and they got paid this summer but it's
the new additions to the team that will
make them so lethal they not only have
the number two overall High School
recruit Michaela Williams in the number
one recruiting class coming in but they
also landed the country's two best
players in the transfer portal both haly
vanith and Ana Mora will be Tigers this
season Morrow and REE finished in the
top 10 in both rebounding and scoring
last season which means LSU is the only
team in the country who was returning
two players who put up those kind of
numbers at this point it's obvious that
LSU has the best starting five and
deepest team in the country but with
players like Caitlyn Clark Paige Beckers
and camon Brink coming for their Crown
the Tigers will really have to make sure
that they're not just a